Bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette FAQ.
Comme c'est la première fois que je me livre à l'exercice,
j'espère que la vidéo ne va pas être trop longue à la fin.
Je voudrais commencer par remercier tous ceux
qui ont posé des questions dans la vidéo d'annonce,
voilà, il y a eu plus de 1000 commentaires
dans la vidéo d'annonce.
Tout n'était pas des questions alors, évidemment,
je n'ai pas pu sélectionner tout
donc j'ai choisi un certain nombre de questions,
il y a beaucoup de questions qui se recoupaient.
Je m'excuse par avance auprès de ceux
dont je n'ai pas pu retenir la question
et j’essaierai dans la vidéo de répondre aussi
par écrit à un maximum de choses.
Voilà, et bien c'est parti !
First !
Ben, ok.
Où vis-tu ?
Je vis à Paris, dans le 13ème arrondissement.
Bonjour, peux-tu nous dire quel a été
ton parcours d'études et nous le raconter un peu ?
Oui, il y a eu pas mal de questions sur les études que j'ai faites,
alors je vais essayer de vous donner un petit aperçu.
Alors, vous vous en serez peut-être douté,
j'ai fait des études scientifiques, j'ai fait un bac S,
à la suite de ça j'ai fait une prépa plutôt maths
et je suis rentré à Normale Sup Lyon et là,
j'ai fait plutôt un cursus physique
et puis assez rapidement, physique théorique.
En fait j'ai fait ce qui, à l'époque,
s'appelait licence, maîtrise, DEA
qui correspond à ce qu'on appelle aujourd’hui L3, M1, M2
et donc j'ai fait un DEA, donc l'équivalent
d'un master recherche en physique théorique.
A la suite de ça, j'ai fait une thèse, un doctorat qui dure 3 ans
et je l'ai fait à moitié entre Lyon et puis le Canada.
As-tu déjà été au Perimeter Institute for Theoretical Physics à Waterloo ?
Et bien oui, c'est là que j'ai fait ma thèse, justement.
Il faut quand même que je vous raconte ce que c'est que
cet endroit parce que c'est un coin assez extraordinaire.
En fait, Waterloo est une ville qui est située
dans l'Ontario près de Toronto
et c'est là qu'il y a notamment le siège de BlackBerry.
A l'époque où j'ai commencé ma thèse,
le PDG et fondateur de BlackBerry
qui est un type qui s'appelle Mike Lazaridis
et qui était assez riche à l'époque on va dire,
a décidé de donner 150 millions de dollars
de sa fortune personnelle
pour créer un institut de recherche en physique fondamentale
dans lequel il inviterait des chercheurs du monde entier
pour travailler sur les grandes questions de l'univers, tout ça.
Et voilà, mon directeur de thèse a été invité là-bas
à peu près au moment où je commençais ma thèse
et donc j'ai eu la chance de faire la majorité de ma thèse là-bas,
dans un endroit assez incroyable.
Pourquoi as-tu choisi la gravité quantique pour ton
sujet de thèse et quel autre sujet aurais-tu pris sinon ?
Oui, mon sujet de thèse était la gravité quantique,
plus précisément la gravité quantique à boucles
et c'était quelque chose sur lequel j'avais
envie de bosser depuis assez longtemps,
en tout cas, le problème de l'unification de la mécanique
quantique et de la relativité générale,
ça faisait déjà pas mal d'années que ça me turlupinait
et j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir aller
jusqu'à poursuivre ce sujet-là en thèse.
Si je n'avais pas fait de la gravité quantique à boucles,
j'aurais probablement essayé de faire la théorie concurrente,
c'est-à-dire de faire de la théorie des cordes.
Je suis très content d'avoir fait de la gravité quantique
à boucles plutôt que de la théorie des cordes.
Dans quelle université as-tu étudié ?
Quel était le sujet précis de ta thèse ?
Alors, l'université, j'en ai parlé.
Le sujet précis de ma thèse c'était:
"Modèles de mousses de spin pour la gravité quantique en 3 dimensions", voilà.
Ta thèse est-elle en accès public et si oui, où la lire ?
Oui, ma thèse est en accès public, elle est sur mon site web
et puis on peut la trouver, je crois,
sur l'archive des thèses en ligne.
Donc si vraiment vous voulez la lire,
c'est assez illisible hein, mais vous pouvez la trouver.
Peut-être que le premier chapitre est lisible.
As-tu déjà parlé avec un astrophysicien ?
Ben, ouais du coup.
Quel est le plus gros coup de bluff que tu aies fait dans ta vie ?
En fait, j'ai fait croire à mes abonnés que j'avais une
thèse en physique théorique alors qu'en fait, pas du tout...
non, je déconne.
Comment fais-tu pour être aussi swag ?
Je n'ai pas compris la question.
Quelles études as-tu faites et quels métiers as-tu exercés ?
Les études j'en ai parlé donc
j'ai terminé mes études par un doctorat
et ensuite pour tout un tas de raisons, je n'ai pas voulu
continuer dans la recherche fondamentale.
La raison principale, c'est que c'est très très difficile
de trouver un vrai job permanent
en recherche fondamentale à l'université,
surtout quand on travaille dans un sujet un peu...
un peu exotique et entre guillemets inutile
comme l'unification de la mécanique quantique
et de la relativité générale.
Donc, à la fin de mon doctorat en fait,
j'ai décidé d'activer mon plan B.
J'ai hésité en fait, entre devenir enseignant
et puis aller faire de la recherche dans l'industrie
et j'ai choisi finalement d'aller dans l'industrie.
A cette époque, je suis rentré donc chez Saint-Gobain
qui est, en fait, toujours la boite où je bosse
aujourd'hui depuis une douzaine d'annèes
et je suis rentré en recherche et développement
d'abord pour faire plutôt des mathématiques.
J'ai travaillé pendant un moment notamment,
sur les application industrielles
de l'intelligence artificielle ou du machine learning
et puis ensuite, je suis revenu un peu plus à la physique
je me suis occupé d'un projet dont le but
était de faire des nouveaux matériaux
super isolants thermique pour isoler les bâtiments.
Ensuite je suis parti, toujours dans la même boite
chez Saint-Gobain, aux Etats-Unis,
c'est à cette époque là que j'ai commencé ma chaîne.
Je suis revenu il y a à peu près un an et je travaille
toujours en recherche et développement,
cette fois plutôt dans le domaine du verre.
Quel est ton métier actuel ?
Actuellement, je suis responsable scientifique
d'un des centres de R&D de Saint-Gobain,
c'est un centre qui est situé près de Compiègne,
au Nord de Paris
et qui travaille sur le verre pour les bâtiments
et le verre automobile.
Comment les collègues et les supérieurs de ton travail
perçoivent ton autre travail sur Youtube ?
Globalement, c'est très bien perçu, évidemment,
beaucoup de gens sont au courant à mon boulot
et ça plait plutôt bien,
il y a beaucoup de gens qui trouvent ça bien,
il y en a qui s'en fichent complètement et c'est leur droit
et puis il y en a toujours quelques uns qui se demandent
ce que je viens faire à faire le guignol sur internet.
Mais voilà, globalement c'est minoritaire
et c'est plutôt bien vu, y compris de ma hiérarchie,
donc ça se passe plutôt bien.
Es-tu le frère de Micmaths ? Il n'y a pas un air
de ressemblance avec Mark Zuckerberg ?
Es-tu le frère de Mark Zuckerberg ? Es-tu l'oncle de Laink de Wankil Studio ?
Alors oui, en fait je suis le fils caché de Micmaths
et de Mark Zuckerberg.
Est-ce que tu serais partant pour me donner
des cours particulier, parce qu'en fait t'es assez canon ?
Alors ça, il va falloir voir ça avec mon agent...
Comment t'es venue la passion pour les sciences ?
Et bien, je n'en sais rien, j'ai l'impression
d'avoir toujours aimé les sciences.
Je pense que ça vient en partie, probablement, de mon père
qui lui aussi était assez passionné notamment plutôt de maths
et moi, c'est vrai que très tôt, j'ai aimé
les petites activités scientifiques,
jouer au petit chimiste, faire des trucs en électronique, etc...
Donc oui, je crois que j'ai toujours aimé les sciences, l'espace
et c'est quelque chose qui ne m'a jamais quitté, voilà.
Y a t-il eu pour toi un élément déclencheur
de ta passion pour la science et si oui, lequel ?
(discussion, cours, découverte, application...)
Alors, déclencheur de ma passion pour la science en général, non,
après, en particulier de ce qui a été mon domaine
de recherche ensuite sur la gravité quantique,
clairement j'ai été beaucoup influencé par un livre
de Stephen Hawking, "Une brève histoire du temps".
Je me souviens du jour où j'ai acheté ce livre,
dans quelles circonstances je l'ai lu
et à l'époque je savais que je voulais faire de la recherche
mais j'hésitais encore entre plusieurs domaines,
la génétique m'intéressait pas mal, par exemple
et a la fin du livre, je me suis dit, non, terminé,
en fait je veux faire de la physique théorique
et je veux comprendre ce qu'il y avait
aux premiers instants de l'univers
donc voilà, c'est comme ça que c'est venu.
D'où te vient cette envie de vulgarisation scientifique ?
Et bien, c'est un peu la rencontre de plusieurs choses.
D'abord, du fait que j'aime la science
donc j'ai envie de le faire partager
et je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas forcement assez populaire aujourd'hui.
On parle beaucoup de culture, littérature, peinture, etc,
mais pour beaucoup de gens la science
ne fait pas partie de la culture
et je pense que la culture scientifique est importante.
Donc voilà, il y a ça d'un côté, l'envie de contribuer à ça
et puis je me suis rendu compte, en fait,
principalement dans le cadre de mon métier
que j'aimais bien vulgariser et que c'était
quelque chose que je faisais plutôt bien
et que j'aimais l'exercice d'essayer de trouver
les astuces pédagogiques qui vont faire que,
on va trouver le truc déclencheur qui fait
que la personne à qui on s'adresse va comprendre.
Voilà, du coup je me suis dit, pourquoi ne pas concilier ça
et le fait que j'ai envie de faire connaitre la science
en commençant à faire de la vulgarisation scientifique,
voilà, c'est comme ça que ça a commencé.
Quel était ton objectif premier lorsque tu as lancé cette chaîne ?
La première chose qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que,
en fait, quand j'ai lancé la chaîne,
je faisais de la vulgarisation depuis pas mal de temps
parce que j'ai commencé à faire de la vulgarisation en 2010
sur un blog, j'ai ouvert le blog en août 2010 je crois,
qui existe toujours et qui s'appelle aussi "Science étonnante".
Et c'est seulement 4-5 ans plus tard, je crois,
fin 2014 début 2015, que j'ai créé la chaîne.
Donc, l'idée de la vulgarisation sur internet,
elle date de bien avant la chaîne,
quelque part, je suis d'abord un blogueur
qui s'est mis à faire des vidéos.
Donc, pourquoi commencer au blog ?
C'est vrai que ça a l'avantage d'être extrêmement facile,
n'importe qui demain peut ouvrir un blog
et commencer à écrire,
c'est quelque chose de très accessible, c'est très facile
d'essayer et le coût d'entrée est très faible.
Et puis après, pourquoi passer à la vidéo ?
Et bien, parce que j'ai compris, peut-être un peu tard,
que c'était un format extrêmement puissant,
je l'avais raconté dans une conférence,
à Lyon Science notamment.
J'ai mis du temps avant de comprendre
la puissance du format vidéo,
pour moi, ça m'a apparu pendant longtemps
comme quelque chose qui était compliqué,
qui prenait du temps, pour lequel il fallait beaucoup de moyens
parce que j'étais trop marqué par
la production télé qui est très... produite.
J'ai mis du temps avant de comprendre que finalement,
ce n'était pas si compliqué que ça de se lancer en format vidéo,
dans un format un peu vlog, on va dire.
Et j'ai mis du temps à comprendre aussi
la puissance pédagogique qu'avait ce format.
Pourquoi "Science étonnante" ?
Ça date de quand j'ai ouvert le blog,
et en fait ma première idée, à l'époque, quand j'ai créé le blog,
je voulais appeler le blog, "Étonnant, non ?",
en référence à Desproges, pour ceux qui connaissent
et puis j'ai créé mon blog, sous WordPress
et, pas de bol, "Étonnant, non ?" sous WordPress était déjà pris,
je me suis dit, ben m*r*e,
il faut que je trouve quelque chose d'autre.
Alors, j'ai réfléchi et voilà, c'est comme ça que
je me suis dit, bon allez, "Science étonnante",
c'est pas très sexy, pas très... ça accroche pas trop, hein,
mais je me suis dit, bon, au moins ça décrit le truc.
Et puis voilà, je suis resté avec ça, quand j'ai créé
la chaîne je n'ai pas vraiment voulu changer de nom.
Alors, je reconnais que c'est un nom un peu plat,
ce n'est pas extrêmement accrocheur,
mais voilà, c'est l'histoire.
Tu maîtrises quels langages informatiques
hormis JavaScript ?
Je ne sais pas où tu as été pêcher
que je maîtrisais JavaScript,
puisque je ne maîtrise pas du tout JavaScript.
Essentiellement, je ne sais pas si on peut dire que
je maîtrise, mais je pratique régulièrement 2 langages,
qui sont Python et R.
Mais je vais probablement finir
par me limiter seulement à Python.
Préfères-tu ta chaîne Youtube ou ton blog ?
C'est deux formats qui sont assez différents,
j'aime vraiment beaucoup les deux,
maintenant j'en fais des choses un peu différentes,
c'est-à-dire, je me sert du blog pour, soit compléter les vidéos,
aller plus loin, j'en parle souvent à la fin des vidéos,
soit de temps en temps aussi, j'écris sur le blog
des articles sans vidéo
qui ont tendance, du coup, à être un petit peu plus technique.
Pour raconter de la science à un niveau
tel que j'essaie de le faire,
c'est-à-dire, en gros je dis toujours que j'essaie
de me placer à peu près au niveau scientifique de lycée.
Je pense que le format vidéo est clairement plus efficace,
maintenant, à titre personnel, j'aime bien me creuser les méninges,
des fois aller faire des choses un peu plus compliquées,
où moi-même je suis moins au clair
et pour ça j'aime beaucoup le format blog
parce qu'il est aussi beaucoup plus interactif.
On parle toujours de Youtube en disant
que c'est quelque chose d'un peu horizontal,
qui met à égalité le créateur et sa communauté,
mais c'est moins interactif.
Je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus facile d'avoir un échange
en commentaires sur un blog que sur Youtube
et puis c'est beaucoup plus facile
aussi de modifier ce qu'on a écrit,
c'est assez souvent que j'ai des échanges
très constructifs dans les commentaires du blog
qui me permettent de modifier des choses ensuite dans le texte
et donc il y a un côté beaucoup plus vivant
alors que la vidéo c'est un peu figé, quand même.
D'expérience, c'est quoi le plus valorisant personnellement,
la recherche ou la vulgarisation scientifique ?
C'est deux choses très différentes
et les deux sont vraiment très valorisants.
Evidemment, quand on fait de la vulgarisation,
qu'on touche un grand nombre de gens
et qu'on a des bons retours, c'est quelque chose
qui est extrêmement valorisant,
je suis très heureux de ce que je fais,
très heureux des retours positifs que j'ai, etc...
La recherche, c'est quelque chose
qui peut être parfois un peu plus binaire
parce que des fois ça marche, des fois ça ne marche pas.
Moi, je suis quelqu'un qui s’amuse beaucoup d'essayer
et même quand ça ne marche pas, je prend du plaisir
à faire de la recherche et à faire de la science.
Juste pour vous donner un exemple de quelque chose
qui est très valorisant sur le plan personnel,
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que j'avais travaillé
pendant un moment, pendant 3 ans en fait,
à essayer de faire des nouveaux matériaux
super isolants thermique pour les bâtiments,
mine de rien, qui est un truc super actuel.
La moitié de l'énergie qu'on crame en France
c'est pour chauffer les bâtiments ou 40%
et donc dans le contexte actuel, avec tous les enjeux
qu'il y a autour des économies d’énergie,
quand on bosse sur un sujet qui est, fabriquer
des nouveaux matériaux super isolants thermique,
je peux vous garantir que le matin on a l'énergie
pour se lever, pour aller essayer des trucs nouveaux
et que le soir quand on se couche on se dit, même
si ça n'a pas marché on n'a pas perdu sa journée.
La recherche, ça peut être extrêmement valorisant.
Comment donnes-tu un sens à ton éphémère
existence sur cette terre en perdition ?
Alors, qu'est-ce que je vais bien pouvoir répondre à ça...
Non, ce que je fais là, par exemple, à travers la vulgarisation
est clairement un truc qui donne du sens,
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à cœur,
dont j'estime que c'est important.
J'ai la chance de pouvoir le faire, y prendre plaisir
et que ça marche donc ça, ça donne un sens.
Comment décrirais-tu ta communauté ?
Alors, c'est toujours un peu difficile...
J'ai évidemment une perception
de ma communauté via les commentaires,
mais on sait que les gens qui commentent
sont vraiment une toute petite minorité du total
et pas forcement toujours une minorité représentative.
Youtube fournit des statistiques dites "démographiques"
sur, notamment les tranches d'âge,
le sexe des gens qui regardent.
Alors, c'est assez...,
C'est assez...,
Pour les tranches d'âge, on se balade typiquement
(j'essaierai de vous mettre les chiffres) entre 15 et 35 ans,
il y a un peu de tout mais...
Par contre, d'après les stats de Youtube, c'est très, très masculin.
Ça, c'est toujours un peu triste quand on est vulgarisateur
scientifique parce qu'il y a un peu ce stéréotype que,
la science c'est moins pour les filles
que pour les garçons, etc...
Donc, j'aimerais apporter ma toute petite pierre
au fait de changer un peu ça,
donc quand j'ai des commentaires de filles qui me disent
qu'elles aiment ce que je fais, ça va toujours dans le bon sens
et c'est vrai que quand on regarde les stats,
d'après Youtube c'est 90 ou 95% de mecs.
Alors, c'est clairement biaisé, pour tout un tas de raison, voilà...
Si je regarde, je crois, sur Facebook
on est plutôt à 70/30, mais bon,
je pense que tous les vulgarisateurs ont un peu ce "problème"
et je crois qu'on a tous très envie de lutter contre ce stéréotype.
Je suis très content quand la barre féminine
de mon audience augmente.
Je me demandais si tes courbes de rétention sont toutes
comme celles que tu as présentées à Lyon, ou pas ?
Oui, j'avais présenté à Lyon une courbe de rétention,
c'est ces courbes qui montrent
combien de temps les gens restent devant la vidéo
ou, par exemple, au bout de 5 minutes de vidéo,
combien de gens sont toujours devant,
par rapport à ceux qui ont commencé.
C'est vraiment un des truc qui m'a absolument surpris,
mais vraiment surpris sur Youtube,
c'est que, quand j'ai vu arriver
les premières courbes de rétention,
je ne m'attendais pas à ce que les gens restent autant.
Je pensais qu'il y avait une érosion et qu'il y avait, à la fin,
toujours systématiquement 5% des gens qui allaient au bout
et en fait non, ce n'est pas du tout le cas,
les gens restent beaucoup,
Ce qui évidemment me fait très plaisir, ça veut dire
que je fais du bon boulot, c'est vraiment fascinant,
alors, ça varie suivant les vidéos, des vidéos
plus complexes ou plus longues,
forcement, à la fin, on n'a pas 70% des gens qui sont là.
Mais, typiquement ça se balade entre 70 et 40%
des gens qui restent jusqu'au bout.
En fait, il y a un certain nombre de personnes
qui partent au début
et après, c'est relativement plat ou,
en tout cas, avec une faible érosion,
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de surprenant,
c'est fascinant et ça fait très plaisir de voir ça.
Bonjour David, je t'ai envoyé un message par mail il y a
quelques semaines et tu ne m'as toujours pas répondu.
Est-ce que c'est parce que tu ne l'as pas lu
ou que tu n'as pas voulu me répondre ?
Oui, comme pas mal de gens, je reçois beaucoup
de messages, de sollicitations, j'en suis très content
et malheureusement je n'ai pas le temps
de répondre à tout le monde.
J'arrive encore, à peu près, à voir tous les commentaires,
du coup, je ne sais pas sur quoi était ton message
en lisant juste ton nom, ça ne me dit rien
et j'avoue que je n'ai pas toujours le temps
de répondre à tout le monde,
soit des sollicitations, sur la chaîne bien sûr,
mais aussi sur Facebook, sur Twitter,
par mail, sur Tipeee, sur le blog, etc...
Voilà, on n'est pas..., je dis "on" parce que je pense que je ne
suis pas le seul vulgarisateur à être dans cette situation,
on n'arrive pas toujours à répondre à tout.
Notamment, un truc où j'ai tendance à ne pas souvent répondre,
c'est quand les gens me posent des questions qui, en fait,
auraient parfaitement été en commentaire de la vidéo
et donc du coup, prendre le temps de faire une réponse
et qu'il n'y ait qu'une personne qui en profite,
ce n'est pas toujours le plus tentant.
Oui j'avoue, je n'arrive pas toujours à répondre
à tout le monde et j'en suis désolé.
A quand une rencontre abonnés en convention ?
Oui, je ne fais pas, généralement, de convention,
en tout cas je n'en ai pas vraiment faite jusqu'ici,
pour une bonne raison qui est que,
comme je bosse à côté, j'ai très peu de temps,
donc je n'ai jamais trouvé un moment où j'avais,
à la fois l'opportunité d'aller en convention
et où j'étais libre, où j'avais l'énergie, etc...
Je n'ai pas vraiment fait de rencontre abonnés,
j'espère que ça ne vous manque pas trop.
J'essaierai peut-être d'en faire quelques-unes
dans les mois à venir,
mais c'est vrai que j'ai rarement l'occasion
de rencontrer ma communauté en vrai.
Contribuer à démocratiser le savoir scientifique
aide-t-il à pécho lors des événementiels geeks ?
Ben, du coup je n'en sais rien...
Est-ce qu'on pourrait te voir, un jour, présenter
une conférence dans une université française ?
Pareil, j'ai eu très peu d'occasions d'aller
présenter des choses dans des universités,
simplement par manque de temps et de disponibilité.
Si j'ai l'occasion de le faire, j'essaierai de le faire
peut-être plus proche de chez moi ,
mais je n'ai pas encore vraiment eu l'occasion
et le temps de le faire.
Penses-tu revenir sur Rennes ?
Oui, je reviendrai à Rennes en 2017,
je ne sais plus très bien la date, mais je vous la mettrai,
je crois que c'est au mois de février ou de mars
et donc je reviendrai à l'espace des sciences pour une conférence,
ça sera une conférence, pas une interview
comme la dernière fois.
Salut, tu as fait plusieurs fois allusion à la Guyane
dans tes vidéos et apparemment tu y vis ?
Alors, pas du tout, je pense que je n'ai jamais parlé
de la Guyane et je n'ai jamais mis les pieds là-bas.
As-tu des envies ou des idées concernant
l'évolution future de ta chaîne ?
Pas d'idée très précise en fait, j'improvise
assez largement, je laisse venir,
je n'ai pas de projet très précis en tête
de faire des trucs très différents
donc je pense que je vais continuer un peu sur le format actuel.
J'ai quelques contacts pour essayer de tester
des formats un petit peu différents
plus sous forme reportage ou interview,
mais je ne me fixe pas spécialement d'objectif particulier
et peut-être qu'il y a de nouvelles choses
qui viendront naturellement.
Penses-tu, à terme, ne faire que des vidéos sur Youtube,
si ton succès continue de croître,
ou alors juste faire ça de temps en temps, par plaisir ?
J'ai plutôt tendance à vouloir faire ça par plaisir
pour tout un tas de raisons,
D'abord parce qu'on sait qu'il n'y a, aujourd'hui,
pas vraiment de modèle économique sur Youtube
qui permette complètement au créateur d'en vivre,
beaucoup font autre chose à côté
et puis le fait de le faire en tant que loisir ou complément
a quand même beaucoup d'avantages parce que ça
ne me met pas de pression, je fais un peu ce que je veux,
je ne me sens pas obligé de traiter des thèmes
dont je sais qu'ils vont être populaires..., voilà,
je fais vraiment ce que je veux, je suis totalement libre
et je trouve ça très bien.
As-tu prévu d'écrire un deuxième livre ?
Oui j'ai prévu, plus que prévu en fait, c'est en cours.
Suite à mon premier livre, mon éditeur
m'a proposé d'en faire un deuxième,
je ne voulais pas vraiment faire un tome 2 dans le même esprit
donc on a passé un peu de temps à essayer de trouver
un angle qui soit un peu intéressant, un peu original
et on a trouvé quelque chose, le plan est fait,
maintenant il faut que je commence à écrire.
Tu as des enfants, je crois. Est-ce que tu as
comme objectif de faire une série pour enfants ?
Alors bonne question, oui c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qui manque aujourd'hui un peu
peut-être dans le paysage de la vulgarisation.
Il y a quelques chaînes qui font ça très bien, je pense
à une chaîne qui s'appelle "Substratum", que j'adore,
qui ne fait pas de la vulgarisation,
c'est plus proche des cours mais je trouve ça super.
Si j'avais le temps, j'aimerais bien faire un truc pour les enfants,
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit là où je sois le meilleur,
je pense qu'il y a plein de gens qui feraient ça mieux que moi.
Mais voilà, aujourd'hui je n'ai pas vraiment le temps
d'explorer un nouveau format comme ça,
mais clairement, il y a un truc à faire
autour de la vulgarisation pour les enfants.
Crois-tu que les vidéos Youtube
comme les tiennes peuvent être un moyen
de révolutionner la manière dont on apprend la science aux gens ?
Alors, il faut être clair sur un truc
et je pense que la plupart des vidéastes vulgarisateurs
tiendront le même discours que moi.
Ce qu'on fait, c'est qu'on n'a pas vocation
à remplacer des cours de sciences.
On fait de la vulgarisation, en gros c'est du domaine
de la culture, on saupoudre des trucs, voilà...
On n'a pas vocation à délivrer un enseignement de sciences
et encore moins à remplacer les enseignants qui le font,
ça, c'est clair.
Maintenant, je pense que, effectivement,
l'enseignement en général va peut-être évoluer,
notamment sous l'impulsion de choses
comme les cours en ligne
et je crois beaucoup à des modèles du type classe inversée
où en fait, finalement, le cours magistral
sera vu en vidéo, chez soi
et on viendra plutôt à l'école pour faire les devoirs
ou en tout cas, tout ce qui est plus de l'ordre du TD, etc...
Je pense que la vidéo en ligne va probablement
bouleverser les modes d'enseignement de cette manière là,
mais je ne crois pas que les vulgarisateurs vidéastes
vont remplacer les profs.
Ta chaîne Youtube et ton blog ne t'on-t-ils jamais donné l'idée
de devenir enseignant chercheur en université
ou en école d'ingénieur ?
Clairement, quand j'ai fini ma thèse,
je m'étais posé la question de savoir,
si vraiment je ne pouvais pas devenir chercheur,
si peut-être je pouvais devenir enseignant,
alors, c'était plutôt lycée, du coup, à ce moment là.
Devenir enseignant chercheur en université
ou en école d'ingénieur,
c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut être dans le domaine
de recherche sur lequel on cherche quelqu'un,
donc l'opportunité ne s'est jamais présentée pour moi
donc en fait, la question ne s'est pas vraiment posée.
Quelques projets hors face-cam dans des laboratoires ?
Oui, j'ai quelques discussions
avec des labos pour aller, justement,
faire quelque chose qui soit plus de l'ordre du reportage,
ou bien de l'interview, etc...
A la fois c'est un format qui me tente,
à la fois c'est un format qui est compliqué
parce qu'il demande tout de suite beaucoup plus d'investissement
en terme de matériel, logistique, de temps, etc...
donc, qui est un peu plus difficile pour moi.
Je pense que j'essaierai d'en faire un,
ne serait-ce que pour tester le concept,
je pense notamment, j'ai des discussions
assez intéressantes avec un labo
sur lequel, je pense, il y a moyen
de faire un truc vraiment sympa.
Mais je ne sais pas dans quelle mesure je pousserai le concept.
Penses-tu que la fréquence des vidéos
pourrait être accélérée avec le temps ?
Je n'ai pas vraiment envie d'augmenter la fréquence des vidéos,
en plus là, on parle d'accélérer la fréquence,
c'est-à-dire lire les secondes.
Non, je n'ai pas vraiment envie d'augmenter
la fréquence des vidéos
parce que ça serait trop compliqué à faire logistiquement.
Aujourd'hui, je suis sur de l'ordre d'une vidéo
toutes les deux semaines, à peu près
et aller au delà de ça, ça serait trop compliqué.
Je pense qu'après aussi peut-être pour vous,
les spectateurs, ça serait peut-être trop.
Je pense qu'une vidéo toutes les deux semaines
c'est un bon rythme, à la fois pour vous et pour moi,
si vous en voulez beaucoup plus, faites le moi savoir,
mais je ne pense pas qu'aujourd'hui,
dans les conditions actuelles, ça soit faisable.
Tu nous offres tout le temps de merveilleuses
vidéos scientifiques à caractère théorique,
comptes-tu faire un jour une expérience en pratique ?
Alors, je ne fais pas beaucoup d'expériences,
j'en ai fait quand même quelques unes,
j'en avais fait sur le pastis, les bulles de savon, voilà,
parce qu'il y a des gens qui font ça très très bien,
évidemment, "ExperimentBoy" par exemple,
mais il y en a d'autres.
Voilà, il y a des gens qui font ça très bien,
moi mon truc c'est plutôt la physique théorique,
mon domaine de spécialité
donc j'ai toujours tendance à faire des chose
où je papote plutôt qu'à faire des manips,
mais je ne crache pas sur en faire une de temps en temps
et s'il y a des idées qui me viennent, ça sera avec plaisir.
De nouvelles collaborations en vue
après celle avec "Heu?reka", très réussie ?
Merci, c'était très sympa de collaborer
avec "Heu?reka", effectivement.
Je n'ai pas fait beaucoup de collaborations,
je crois que je n'en ai fait que deux,
j'ai fait celle avec "Heu?reka" sur le Bitcoin
et j'en avais fait une avec "CodeMU"
sur la machine qui invente des mots.
La raison, c'est que je ne veux pas faire de la collab
juste pour faire de la collab,
l'idée c'est de faire un truc qui ait du sens,
vraiment où la collaboration se justifie,
au-delà du plaisir de faire un truc ensemble
et du coup, je ne l'ai fait que quand ça se présentait
et qu'il y avait vraiment un truc qui avait du sens
du coup, plutôt dans des domaines
hors de mon domaine de spécialité,
que ce soit l'économie ou bien la langue.
J'ai quelques idées qui traînent, comme ça,
avec des gens avec qui je n'en ai pas forcement parlé.
Donc voilà, j'en ferai peut-être d'autres mais je ne cours pas non plus après beaucoup de collabs.
Est-ce que tu es en contact avec d'autres vidéastes
de vulgarisation scientifique
pour éviter une redondance des sujets ?
Déjà, on est tous en contact, à peu près,
les uns avec les autres,
notamment dans la vulgarisation scientifique,
il y a "VidéoSciences",
je vous recommande d'aller sur la page de "VidéoSciences"
et on a une petite mailing list qui fait
qu'on se parle tous, on se connait tous.
Sur la redondance des sujets, en fait,
globalement, on s'en fout un peu .
Je suis toujours légèrement agacé
quand je reçois des commentaires du genre,
"Ah oui, mais non, machin en avait déjà parlé"
Je veux dire, c'est pas grave ! On a le droit de parler d'un sujet,
même si machin en avait déjà parlé il y a 6 mois ou 3 ans.
Aucun vulgarisateur n'est propriétaire
exclusif des sujets qu'il traite
et c'est même plutôt bien parce qu'on a tous
des approches un peu différentes, donc c'est très bien.
Si on est plusieurs à traiter le même sujet,
je ne crois pas du tout que ça fasse redondance,
en tout cas moi, je n'en tient pas compte.
Je voulais poser une question, mais je suis obligé
de poser celle-ci d'abord: on vous vouvoie ou on te tutoie ?
As you wish.
(Comme tu le souhaites)
Quel âge avait Rimbaud ?
Ben, il n'était pas né, je crois...
Une passion en dehors des sciences ?
Oui, plusieurs passions même, je fais,
en tout cas j'ai fait beaucoup de musique,
j'en fais un peu moins aujourd'hui,
j'en fais un peu des fois pour la chaîne
pour faire les petits jingles ou les petites intros.
Sinon, je joue au badminton.
Je suis un mordu de jeux de société,
c'est un peu old school à l'heure des jeux vidéos
mais j'aime bien faire des jeux de société.
Voilà, quelques exemples de passions qui m'occupent.
Musicien n'est-ce pas ? Un petit morceau pour la FAQ ?
Non, je ne vais peut-être pas vous jouer
un morceau tout de suite,
mais comme je vous disais, tout ce qui est sur la chaîne,
quasiment, a été fait par moi
pour une raison qui est que, en fait, quand
j'ai commencé à vouloir mettre des musiques, etc,
ce n'était pas du tout clair dans ma tête pour moi
les questions de droits, de trucs comme ça,
même quand c'était des trucs supposément libres.
Donc, pour ne pas prendre de risques, je me suis dit,
je vais tout faire moi-même et puis ça m'amusait.
Voilà, tout ce que vous entendez musicalement,
sauf exception, auquel cas c'est précisé
sur la chaîne, en fait c'est moi qui l'ai fait.
Si vous voulez me voir jouer de la guitare,
je joue un peu dans l'épisode que j'ai tourné
avec la chaîne "String Theory", sur l'acoustique.
Raconte-nous ton parcours musical.
Moi, j'ai commencé par la guitare en fait, quand j'étais ado
parce que je me suis dit que c'était
quand même pratique pour draguer.
J'ai fait beaucoup de guitare principalement,
assez vite je me suis mis à faire du rock progressif
qui était une musique que j'aimais bien.
J'ai fait aussi beaucoup de funk
donc j'ai joué dans plein de groupes,
un peu dans ces deux styles là assez différents
et puis, sur le tard, je me suis mis à apprendre
d'autres instruments, j'ai appris la basse,
j'ai appris un peu la batterie, j'ai joué un peu
dans un groupe, j'ai chanté
et puis je me suis mis aussi au piano en autodidacte
donc je suis un mauvais pianiste,
mais ça m'amuse beaucoup.
Tes guitaristes favoris.
Alors principalement, on va dire David Guilmour,
le guitariste de Pink Floyd,
Mark Knopfler, celui de Dire Straits, voilà,
et puis sinon, plutôt les classiques du rock,
Jimmy Paige, Slash, Carlos Santana,
des gens qui ne sont pas forcement toujours les méga virtuoses,
mais c'est des mecs qui ont un style,
ils jouent, n'importe qui les reconnait.
Une fois ou deux tu as parlé des échecs. Quel est ton élo ?
Oui, j'ai parlé, je crois, deux fois des échecs quand j'ai fait
une vidéo sur le poker et que j'en ai fait une sur le go
et c'est marrant, en revoyant celle sur le go, je crois,
je parle des échecs sur un ton qui laisse penser
que je suis, à la fois, connaisseur et amateur,
d'où la question, j'imagine, sur l'élo.
Alors, en fait non, pas du tout, je suis nul aux échecs
et je déteste les échecs.
Je n'aime pas parce que je trouve ça hyper froid,
il n'y a pas du tout de hasard, il n'y a pas de thème.
Je suis désolé pour tous les gens qui aiment les échecs,
c'est juste un avis personnel
et du coup je n'aime pas trop jouer aux échecs
parce que je trouve ça...
en plus quand on perd, comme il n'y a pas de hasard,
c'est vraiment juste qu'on est plus con que l'autre.
Je n'aime pas trop les échecs,
je suis un fan de ces jeux de plateau
où il y a plein de pions partout où il y a une part de hasard
mais voilà, désolé, les échecs j'avoue que je n'aime pas.
Es-tu jamais devenu accro à un jeu vidéo et si oui, lequel ?
Accro, je pense que le seul exemple c'est "Civilization",
le 2 ou le 3 quand j'étais plus jeune,
depuis j'évite d'y rejouer pour éviter
de flinguer une cinquantaine d'heures.
Sinon, là ça ne va parler qu'aux plus anciens,
j'ai été super accro à un jeu d’enquête policière
qui s’appelait "Maupiti Island" sur Atari ST,
le meilleur jeu vidéo de tous les temps.
♪ [Musique de jeu vidéo] ♪
Et puis sinon... "Mario Kart".
Est-ce que ton tableau derrière est de Jeremy Mann ?
Non, les tableaux que l'on voit en fond dans les vidéos,
j'ai du en faire un ou deux différents,
ce sont des tableaux d'un peintre
qui s'appelle Doutreleau
et en fait, les deux types de tableaux
que j'ai mis dans les vidéos,
c'est des représentations d'avenues de New York.
J'adore Doutreleau j'ai plusieurs
reproductions de lui chez moi,
il a vraiment un style que j'aime beaucoup et donc voilà, Doutreleau,
je vous encourage à aller regarder ce qu'il fait.
Niveau lecture, c'est qui tes écrivains de chevet ?
Alors, je ne sais pas si j'ai des écrivains de chevet,
si je réfléchi à ceux dont je lis tout ou presque,
je pense qu'il y en deux,
c'est Ken Follett qui fait notamment des romans
historiques qui sont absolument fabuleux
et puis dans le genre polar plutôt, Grangé,
je pense que j'ai dû lire à peu près tout ce qu'il a fait.
Sinon, il y a plein de trucs que j'aime,
mais les deux écrivains dont vraiment
je lis tout les yeux fermés, c'est ces deux-là
Quel est ton livre préféré, ton film préféré, ta série préférée ?
Alors livre..., je pense que ça pourrait être...
"Les Piliers de la Terre" de Ken Follett
qui est un truc de malade si vous ne connaissez pas
"Les Piliers de la Terre".
Un roman historique qui se passe au 11ème siècle en
Angleterre et qui raconte la construction des cathédrales.
Ça ne parait pas sexy comme ça,
mais c'est juste un bouquin fabuleux.
Et puis sinon, un livre qui m'a énormément marqué,
ce n'est pas très original, mais c'est "Le Seigneur des Anneaux".
Je me revois encore, collégien, passant des heures
à lire "Le Seigneur des Anneaux",
c'est évidemment un livre qui est un peu particulier
pour moi, comme pour beaucoup de gens.
Film préféré,
alors, c'est toujours du domaine un peu arbitraire
de décréter qu'un de nos films est préféré.
Si je devais en citer un, je citerais
"La Cité des Enfants Perdus" de Caro et Jeunet.
Et série préférée,
c'est pareil il y a plein de trucs mais, pour citer un truc
un peu original, on va dire 'The Newsroom".
A quoi est-ce que tu ressembles par derrière ?
On ne voit que ton visage dans toutes les vidéos.
Ça, il va falloir voir avec mon agent.
Vous semblez être un touche-à-tout scientifique,
vos sujets sont variés,
parmi les sujets que vous avez traités en vidéo,
y en a-t-il que vous ne connaissiez que peu
et qui vous ont demandé des recherches intenses ?
Oui, évidemment je ne maîtrise pas de naissance
tous les sujets dont je parle.
Quand je parle de maths ou de physique, c'est souvent
des choses que je connais, voire que je connais bien,
quand je parle de bio ou plus de sciences sociales
forcement c'est des choses que je connais moins bien
et qui me demandent pas mal de travail.
Donc oui, je fais pas mal de recherches
sur un certain nombre de sujets.
Où te procures-tu les documents nécessaires
à tes vidéos en général ?
Tes moyens d'avoir des sources solides ?
Alors, la grande question des sources...
Quand c'est un sujet que je connais bien, en général,
mes sources peuvent être tout simplement
mes cours de licence ou de maîtrise.
Après, de manière générale, pour traiter un sujet
et trouver les bonnes sources,
c'est relativement simple, Wikipédia est très bien fait.
C'est-à-dire que l'avantage de Wikipédia c'est que,
en général, les articles sont plutôt bien faits
et ça nous pointe quels sont les grands domaines
importants qu'il va falloir considérer,
mais surtout, Wikipédia cite les sources et souvent
cite les publications scientifiques.
Donc moi, quand j'attaque un nouveau sujet
sur lequel je ne suis vraiment pas à l'aise,
je pense notamment à tout ce que je peux raconter en biologie,
en général je fais toujours la même chose,
Wikipédia et je vais lire les articles scientifiques
d'origine, vraiment les publications, en anglais et tout...
Parfois c'est un peu violent,
quand on n'est pas du domaine de recherche,
mais c'est vraiment le meilleur moyen d'être sûr
qu'on ne raconte pas de conneries.
Donc, je me sers en fait de Wikipédia
comme une source de sources
et ensuite je vais, au maximum,
lire les articles scientifiques.
Peux-tu nous partager un peu les coulisses,
la préparation, l'écriture, etc... ?
Ça pourrait inspirer les autres prochains
vulgarisateurs scientifiques.
Je ne vais pas tout vous faire là, mais il se trouve
qu'en fait on m'avait déjà posé cette question
et je me suis dit que j'allais écrire un billet de blog
pour répondre à cette question et parler de tout,
c'est-à-dire comment je fais la recherche, quel matos
j'utilise, les trucs et astuces, les logiciels, etc...
Je ne sais pas si au moment où la vidéo va sortir
le billet de blog sera prêt,
mais je vous mettrai le lien quelque part
où je vous explique absolument tout des coulisses.
As-tu un texte quand tu tournes tes vidéos ? Tu arrives
à faire des monologues avec très peu de montage,
c'est quoi le secret, un prompteur, la science infuse...?
Alors, ce n'est rien de tout ça.
Dans les vidéos classiques, ce n'est pas des longs
monologues, en général j'ai plein de coupures,
certaines sont visibles, d'autres ne le sont pas parce qu'il peut
y avoir des animations ou des choses comme ça,
mais toute la vidéo n'est pas enregistrée d'une seule traite.
Il y a des cas où j'ai enregistré d'une seule traite
notamment quand j'ai fait les vidéos dites "à chaud"
et là, effectivement, c'est un long monologue.
En général je les ai faites sur des sujets
que je connaissais relativement bien,
je m'étais quand même écrit un petit plan à l'avance,
mais non, pas de prompteur,
c'était de l'improvisation, voilà.
Salut, je fais partie des fans
qui n'ont pas fait du tout d'études scientifiques
et qui adorent que tu mettes à leur portée
des concepts qui, sans cela,
seraient restés pour eux des notions complètement hermétiques.
Ça me fait hyper plaisir quand je lis ce genre de commentaire,
c'est pour ce genre de choses qu'on fait de la vulgarisation.
Mon but ce n'est pas de faire de la vulgarisation,
"les chercheurs parlent aux chercheurs",
c'est vraiment de toucher des gens qui autrement
n'auraient peut-être pas été touchés par ces choses-là.
Donc ce genre de commentaire me fait hyper plaisir, continuez.
Quels sont, selon toi, les ingrédients
indispensables dans une vidéo
pour rendre compréhensibles des choses aussi complexes.
Les ingrédients... moi je dirais,
j'ai un principe qui est très simple,
mais qui est très compliqué à mettre en oeuvre,
c'est le fait que quand on fait de la vulgarisation,
il faut se mettre à la place de l'auditoire qu'on vise.
C'est facile à dire, c'est très difficile à faire
parce qu'il faut tout le temps veiller à être sûr
que ce qu'on dit va être compréhensible,
qu'on ne va pas faire des raccourcis, qu'on ne va pas utiliser
un mot sans avoir expliqué ce que veut dire ce mot, etc...
C'est un effort constant, notamment à l'écriture, de se dire,
qu'est-ce qu'il va se passer dans la tête de celui ou de celle
qui me regarde et qui écoute cette phrase à ce moment là.
C'est ça le seul et unique secret,
c'est de se mettre à la place de son auditoire
et ça ne marche pas que pour la vulgarisation.
Les analogies étant la clé de la vulgarisation,
j'aimerais connaitre leurs origines,
sont-elles le pur produit de ton imagination ?
Oui, les analogies on en utilise tout le temps en vulgarisation,
un certain nombre que j'utilise
sont des analogies classiques
et puis de temps en temps, j'en trouve moi-même.
C'est un des moments les plus "jouissifs"
au moment de la phase d'écriture,
c'est quand on arrive à trouver une analogie
qui est nouvelle, qu'on n'avait pas lue avant
et qui colle parfaitement et donc on se dit,
là je vais raconter ça
et là ça va faire clic dans leur tête et ils vont comprendre.
C'est vraiment le truc le plus savoureux,
de trouver la bonne analogie, la bonne porte d’entrée,
voilà, ça c'est vraiment passionnant.
Quelles limites t'imposes-tu dans tes vidéos
pour les rendre plus accessibles
que tu ne t'imposes pas dans tes billets ?
En gros, quand on fait de la vulgarisation,
il faut se fixer un niveau de public cible,
pas forcement un niveau d'age ou un truc comme ça,
mais un niveau de prérequis.
En gros, quand moi je fais une vidéo, quand j'écris,
je me dis, les gens qui vont m'écouter ont, en gros,
un niveau scientifique qui correspond à peu près
à ce qu'on apprend au lycée, enfin, des restes de lycée.
Ça peut être des gens qui sont au lycée actuellement,
ou des gens qui ont fini le lycée depuis très longtemps,
mais qui ont des vagues restes de lycée.
Je cite toujours un peu les mêmes exemples,
c'est-à-dire que je suppose que,
si je parle d'un gène ou d'ADN,
les gens ont une vague idée de ce que c'est,
si je parle d'une force, les gens savent à peu près ce que c'est.
Donc je part du principe que les gens ont un niveau
restes de lycée et puis je construis à partir de là.
Ça c'est ce que je faisais avant dans le blog
et c'est ce que je fais dans mes vidéos
et du coup maintenant dans le blog je me permets
d'être un petit peu plus..., parfois un peu plus violent.
Donc il m'arrive des fois de traiter certains sujets où, en gros,
des fois je fais des dérives et vont comprendre
les gens qui ont fait des études supérieures en sciences
et d'autres ne vont pas forcement apprécier tout ça.
Donc, j'essaye de rester niveau lycée dans les vidéos
et je me lâche un peu plus dans le blog.
Combien de temps passes-tu, en moyenne,
sur une vidéo et les différentes phases,
recherche, illustration, tournage, montage ?
Je passe en moyenne sur une vidéo, une quinzaine d'heures,
ce n'est pas énorme parce que
je suis assez organisé, on va dire.
Recherche et écriture, ça va prendre 5, 6, 7 heures,
c'est à peu près cet ordre de grandeur,
le tournage en lui-même, c'est assez rapide,
en général c'est juste une heure
et puis après, montage et illustration, à nouveau
7 ou 8 heures, à peu près cet ordre de grandeur.
Après, ça dépend beaucoup des vidéos, de leur longueur
et puis de la maîtrise que j'ai du sujet au départ,
mais l'ordre de grandeur c'est à peu près
une quinzaine d'heures par vidéo.
Comment parviens-tu à concilier ta vie de youtubeur,
qui doit prendre un temps énorme,
à ta vie familiale et professionnelle.
Ma vie de youtubeur ne me prend pas tant de temps que ça
parce que je vous ai dit, une quinzaine d'heures par vidéo,
je fais à peu près une vidéo toutes les deux semaines,
ce qui fait que j'y passe, en moyenne, 8 heures par semaine.
Donc, 8 heures par semaine c'est beaucoup,
mais ce n'est pas très différent de gens qui peuvent pratiquer
un sport ou un instrument à un niveau très intense,
c'est un loisir chronophage mais ce n'est pas non plus...
Du coup, je suis vraiment très organisé
pour arriver à tenir ces timings là,
donc à la fois, je prépare très bien mes tournages,
mes phases d'écriture,
c'est toujours très clair, qu'est-ce que je fais et à quel moment.
Je vais aussi au minimum...,
je ne vais pas passer 3 heures à faire un effet spécial sur un plan,
je n'ai pas le temps de le faire, je pense qu'il vaut mieux
que je consacre mon énergie
à faire des trucs pour lesquels on regarde les vidéos.
Je n'ai pas le temps de passer du temps
à faire des fioritures donc je n'en fait pas beaucoup,
c'est pour ça que j'ai un style qui peut être...
assez sobre on va dire.
Je me concentre sur l'essentiel et c'est le moyen
que j'ai trouvé pour tout concilier.
Quelles sont les mesures que vous avez prises
pour maximiser la portée de vos vidéos ?
Je n'ai pris aucune mesure pour maximiser
la portée de mes vidéos
à part peut-être essayer de faire des bonnes vidéos qui,
j'espère, reste le principe numéro 1.
Une chose que j'ai essayée, parce que j'ai voulu tester...,
il y a une légende urbaine qui dit que
l'algorithme de YouTube met plus en avant les vidéos
monétisées, moi je ne monétise pas mes vidéos
et donc un jour quand même,
en bon scientifique, j'ai voulu essayer
et donc j'ai monétisé une de mes vidéos, j'ai une vidéo
monétisée, je vous laisse chercher laquelle,
pour voir s'il y avait effectivement un effet sur
le nombre de vues et je n'ai pas vu d'effet, donc voilà...
Je m'efforce de ne pas céder à toutes ces modes
qui consistent à faire des "tops",
ou bien à faire des miniatures qui se ressemblent toutes,
c'est-à-dire avec un gros plan d'une tête
sur un fond, écrit en jaune, enfin bref...
Donc, j'essaye de maximiser la portée de mes vidéos
en faisant des bonnes vidéos, voilà, j'espère que j'y arrive.
Question de Scilabus, dont je vous encourage à aller voir la chaîne,
Je suis assez impressionnée
par la diversité des sujets que tu traites,
mais surtout par le niveau de profondeur dans lequel tu vas.
Est-ce que tu fais appel à des experts
quand ce n'est pas tes domaines de prédilection ?
Alors, assez peu, en fait.
Comme je disais, quand ce n'est pas mon domaine de
prédilection, j'essaie de me taper les publications scientifiques.
Il est arrivé quand même une fois ou deux que je demande,
soit que je pose des questions à des gens dont je savais
que c'était plus le domaine de recherche,
soit une fois ou deux aussi, j'ai fait carrément relire
un script pour vérifier qu'il n'y avait pas de grosse boulette,
mais non, globalement, j'essaye de trouver par moi-même.
Salut, tes vidéos sont déjà très complètes,
mais tu es parfois obligé de n'effleurer
que la surface ce certains sujets complexes.
Pourquoi ne pas les approfondir
dans un autre format de vidéo plus typé "cours"?
Alors oui, le problème c'est que, encore une fois,
je n'ai pas le temps de faire des formats de ce genre là,
qui en plus, fatalement, toucherait un public beaucoup
plus restreint, demanderait aussi pas mal d'efforts.
Je n'ai pas, jusqu'ici, eu la volonté d'aller
dans des choses plus complexes, plus typées cours.
Si jamais vous avez envie de ce genre de vidéo,
il y a des choses très bien sur YouTube,
vous pouvez notamment aller voir
la chaîne qui s'appelle "Science4All"
où Lê a justement différents types de vidéos
avec des niveaux différents
et même, si vous voulez des trucs hardcores,
il a une série qui s'appelle Hardcore.
Voilà, si vous voulez des choses plus complexes,
plus typées cours où il y a plus de détails,
qui va plus en profondeur, vous pouvez aller voir "Science4All".
As-tu des livres scientifiques, plutôt de vulgarisation
ou bien plus poussés à nous conseiller en particulier ?
Un peu lié à la question précédente,
j'ai souvent des demandes
pour aller plus loin, mais vraiment en profondeur,
c'est-à-dire des gens qui veulent aller au-delà de la
vulgarisation qui ne sont pas à l'université, ou quoi...,
mais qui ont vraiment envie de, par exemple, faire
de la mécanique quantique vraiment profondément.
Il y a un livre et aussi une série de vidéos
que je recommande pour ça,
qui ont été faites par Leonard Susskind
qui est un des papes de la théorie des cordes.
Et donc il a fait une série de vidéos, je crois
que c'était à Stanford ou à Caltech, je ne sais plus
et il a fait aussi un livre, une série de livres qui s'appelle
"The Theoretical Minimum", "Le Minimum Théorique",
il y en a quelques-uns qui ont été traduits en français.
L'objectif de ce que fait Susskind, c'est vraiment ça, c'est de dire,
vous avez fini les études depuis longtemps,
vous voulez vraiment faire de la mécanique quantique,
mais pas de la vulgarisation, rentrer dans le dur,
il s'adresse à ces gens-là et donc on se tape
les maths et les trucs comme ça.
C'est le seul vraiment qui, à mon avis, réponde à ça,
après, ce n'est pas une promenade de santé donc
si vous voulez vous lancer là-dedans, il faut être prêt.
Es-tu gay ?
Non, je ne crois pas, mais il faut demander à mon agent.
As-tu quelques bonnes chaînes de vulgarisation
à nous recommander ?
Oui, il y en a plein, allez sur le portail de "VidéoSciences",
il y a plein de super chaînes,
moi je suis quasiment abonné à toutes
et il y en a je crois, peut-être une centaine
donc ce n'est pas les bonnes chaines
de vulgarisation qui manquent,
je vous en recommandais quelques-unes avant
et je vous en recommanderai quelques-unes après,
mais allez voir le portail de "VidéoSciences".
Ce serait intéressant de faire des vidéos trimestrielles des
nouveautés qui ont été trouvées dans les sciences en général.
Alors justement, il y a quelqu'un qui fait ça très bien,
c'est la chaîne qui s'appelle "Science de comptoir"
et qui a une petite émission périodique,
je crois tous les mois ou tous les deux mois
qui s'appelle "L'Eurêkap" et qui fait exactement ça,
donc allez voir "L'Eurêkap ".
Avec la popularité grandissante des chaînes éducatives,
on remarque l'apparition de chaînes plus sensationnalistes
voire plus proches du spectacle de magie
que de la méthode scientifique.
Ce genre de contenu mérite-t-il vraiment
de faire partie de l’écosystème éducatif de YouTube
ou est-ce plus un divertissement scientisé ?
Oui clairement, sur YouTube, comme à la télé,
il y a du divertissement scientisé.
Moi je crois que ce n'est pas un mal,
il y a de la place pour tout.
Quand on s'adresse à des gens qui ont très très peu
de contacts avec la science,
c'est normal de passer par du divertissement scientisé,
donc moi je trouve ça très bien, ce n'est pas mal,
c'est bien que ça existe, ça va attirer des gens.
Il faut de tout, il faut des choses qui soient
très rigoureuses et un peu chiantes,
il faut des choses qui soient très divertissantes et peu rigoureuses,
mais il n'y a pas un mode de vulgarisation
qui est intrinsèquement meilleur que l'autre.
Tu connais arduino ?
Oui, je connais arduino, j'adore,
j'ai découvert ça il y a un an ou deux
et j'ai notamment beaucoup appris grâce à une chaîne
qui s'appelle "U=RI" que je vous encourage à aller voir.
As-tu des youtubeurs que tu admires ou que tu aimes
juste pour le contenu qu'ils proposent ?
Alors, vaste question, je vais vous en citer quelques-uns
peut-être un peu en dehors des sciences.
Il y a une chaîne qui s'appelle "Les Parasites",
c'est des gens qui font des courts-métrages,
c'est une bande de jeunes, ils sont juste incroyables.
Ils ont déjà pas mal d'abonnés, je crois qu'ils ont
200 000 abonnés, mais ils méritent 100 fois plus.
Ils font des court-métrages absolument hallucinants
de qualité, de scénario, etc...,
donc si vous ne connaissez pas "Les Parasites",
allez voir les "Les Parasites".
Sinon, dans les youtubeurs que j'admire,
je pourrais citer "LinksTheSun" par exemple.
Je trouve que ce qu'il fait notamment
avec les points culture est un truc de dingue.
Je repense notamment à son épisode sur la musique
classique, il fait 30 minutes sur la musique classique,
qui a 1 million de vues
(2 millions en fait)
et je me dis, l'impact de cette vidéo
sur la promotion de la musique classique
est un truc qui dépasse tout ce qui a pu être fait
par ailleurs, je trouve ça franchement fascinant
et je trouve absolument génial qu'il ait fait ça.
Sinon, un autre exemple anglophone cette fois,
c'est pareil, d'une chaîne qui n'est pas du tout reconnue
à sa juste valeur, c'est "acapellascience".
C'est quelqu’un qui s'amuse à faire des chansons
sur la science en acapella
en reprenant des thèmes de chansons existantes
et c'est un truc de malade
donc vous pouvez aller voir "Bohemian Gravity"
qui est fait sur l'air de "Bohemian Rhapsody"
ou vous pouvez aller voir celle
qu'il a faite récemment sur CRISPR/CAS9
ou bien celle qui s'appelle "Entropic Time".
Est-ce que les scientifiques de métier sont, eux aussi,
soumis aux biais cognitifs de notre "crétin de cerveau"
Oui malheureusement, ce n'est pas parce qu'on connait
les biais cognitifs qu'on arrive à s'en prémunir tout le temps,
mais c'est toujours intéressant, de temps en temps,
de se poser la question,
de se dire, est-ce que je ne suis pas en train de favoriser
ma propre hypothèse parce qu'elle me plait, etc...
Donc oui malheureusement,
les scientifiques sont aussi soumis à ça.
Qui est le/la scientifique que tu admires le plus et pourquoi ?
Quel est le scientifique qui t'a le plus marqué
ou inspiré et pourquoi ?
C'est une question un peu différente parce que ça fait
plutôt référence à des gens que j'ai pu rencontrer .
Il y a un scientifique qui m'a quand même
pas mal marqué, dans mon orientation en tout cas,
C'est un des fondateurs de la gravité quantique
à boucles, qui était mon sujet de thèse
et en fait, avant de commencer ma thèse,
je ne le connaissais pas,
j'ai commencé à lire des articles de lui,
à être fasciné par sa manière de raconter les choses
et la démarche qu'il proposait
et voilà, c'est notamment ça qui m'a complètement attiré
vers la gravité quantique à boucles.
Je n'ai pas fait ma thèse avec lui, mais j'ai fait
mon stage de DEA, à l'époque, avec lui,
régulièrement on travaille ensemble et
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui m'a beaucoup inspiré.
Quelle est ta physicienne préférée ?
Alors, je dirais... en tout cas dans les découvertes
les plus fascinantes faites par des physiciennes,
je dirais Henrietta Leavitt,
qui a démontré notamment le lien qui existerait
entre la luminosité et la période d'oscillation
de certaines étoiles variables
et c'est un truc absolument fondamental
parce que c'est ça qui nous permet
de mesurer les distances dans l'univers,
c'est ça qui nous permet de dire, telle étoile
est à telle distance ou telle galaxie, etc...
Donc c'est un truc essentiel
dans l’astronomie d'aujourd'hui
et c'est elle qui a mis en évidence
cette relation pour la première fois,
une découverte fabuleuse.
Tu préfères les maths ou la physique ?
C'est très différent, je suis quand même
physicien à la base, mais...
j'aime bien les maths pour le jeu de l'esprit,
mais aussi parce que c'est utile en physique.
On peut comparer ça, par exemple, à un sport
et puis au fait que pour pratiquer un sport
il faut de la musculation, de l'endurance, etc...
Les maths c'est un outil qui permet d'être meilleur
dans le sport, le vrai sport, qu'est la physique.
Je me demandais, quel était ton théorème préféré ?
Ça, je ne sais pas, mais j'avais fait une vidéo
sur le théorème des 4 couleurs,
c'est quand même probablement un des plus fascinants.
Quelle est la formule mathématique qui te fascine le plus ?
Formule mathématique, je ne sais pas,
il y a quelques formules qui sont liées notamment à pi
qui sont toujours assez fascinantes.
Je vais quand même vous citer
une formule de physique plutôt, c'est R.
R en fait, c'est le lagrangien de la relativité générale,
je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails,
mais en physique théorique, souvent,
pour définir le contenu d'une théorie,
il faut donner ce qu'on appelle son lagrangien.
Des fois les lagrangiens peuvent être très compliqués,
le lagrangien de la physique des particules
est affreusement compliqué
et le lagrangien de la relativité générale, c'est juste R,
le scalaire de Ricci pour ceux qui connaissent.
Que penses-tu des non-universitaires qui affirment avoir
résolu des problèmes comme l'hypothèse de Riemann ?
La recherche indépendante et autodidacte est-elle néfaste ?
Non, globalement elle n'est pas néfaste,
l'expérience prouve que 99% du temps
ces autodidactes, en fait, se plantent.
Il y a un contre-exemple assez joli, il n'y a pas longtemps
j'en ai parlé dans ma vidéo sur les nombres premiers,
alors on ne parle pas d'un autodidacte, mais on parle de
quelqu'un qui était complètement hors du système de recherche,
qui a fait une avancée essentielle concernant certaines
variantes de la conjecture des nombres premiers jumeaux
et l'exemple est intéressant, parce que la communauté
mathématique a très très vite reconnu ce qu'il avait fait,
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas eu une phase de contestation,
"non, non, ce n'est pas un mec du système" et tout...
Quand les mecs qui ne sont pas dans le système
écrivent des trucs qui ne sont pas des conneries,
le système a vite fait d'accepter ça.
Donc tous les scientifiques ou pseudo-scientifiques
indépendants qui démontrent des trucs sur,
Einstein s'était trompé, machin...,
malheureusement en général, c'est des conneries.
Peux-tu prendre 5 secondes de ta vidéo FAQ
pour clairement dire à tous
que les travaux de Nassim Haramein = Bullshit ?
Et bien oui, les travaux de Nassim Haramein = Bullshit,
en tout cas, ce qu'il a pu produire jusqu'ici.
Voilà, exemple de physicien/pseudo-physicien indépendant
qui prétend avoir démontré des trucs
qui ne tiennent pas du tout la route.
Donc oui, je sais, il est assez populaire
mais à l'heure actuelle, non, ce n'est pas de la science.
Je suis en terminale S, passionné par les maths et la
physique, j'aimerais faire de la recherche, que faire et où ?
Pour faire de la recherche, pour en faire son métier,
il faut passer par un doctorat, une thèse,
il y a plusieurs moyens d'arriver jusqu'au doctorat.
Il y a essentiellement deux voies.
On va dire, la voie classique, c'est de faire
un cursus universitaire, après le bac,
de faire licence, master et ensuite le doctorat
et puis il y a une voie alternative
qui consiste à faire plutôt une prépa,
puis une école d'ingénieur et puis à récupérer un master
en dernière année d'école d'ingénieur.
Les deux solutions ont leurs avantages et leurs inconvénients,
la voie purement universitaire, l'avantage
c'est qu'elle est faite pour mener au doctorat,
elle a un inconvénient, c'est que si jamais on se plante,
c'est un peu plus difficile de retomber sur ses pattes,
alors que c'est plus facile avec un diplôme d’ingénieur.
L'inconvénient de la voie ingénieur,
c'est qu'elle a tendance à nous amener vers des choses
qui sont différentes de celles du doctorat.
Si vous êtes dans cette situation, regardez bien
quelles sont les écoles d'ingénieurs
qui ont tendance à former des gens au doctorat,
il y en a qui n'en forment presque pas
et d'autres qui en forment un certain nombre.
Que conseillerais-tu comme études
à quelqu'un passionné de physique
qui veut devenir chercheur en physique fondamentale ?
Voilà, j'ai donné juste avant
le type de parcours qu'il fallait suivre.
Des conseils, c'est un domaine qui est très,
très, très, très compétitif, avec très peu de places.
Juste pour vous donner quand même
un ordre de grandeur, l'année où j'ai fini ma thèse,
le nombre de postes disponibles au CNRS
dans mon domaine..., il y avait 2 postes disponibles
et il y avait plus de 110 candidats, je crois.
Voilà, il faut savoir que les probabilités de succès
sont vraiment très très faibles,
donc un conseil essentiel quand on veut de lancer
dans ce genre de parcours, c'est d'avoir un plan B.
On sait que tu as une thèse en physique théorique,
mais aujourd’hui tu fais de la recherche appliquée.
Qu'est-ce qui t'as poussé à ne pas poursuivre
dans la voie de la recherche fondamentale ?
Et bien voilà, c'est ce que je viens de vous raconter,
les probabilités de succès sont très très faibles
et donc une fois que j'ai eu fini ma thèse, je n'avais
quasiment aucune chance de choper un job.
Il aurait fallu que j’enchaîne ce qu'on appelle
des post-doc qui sont, en gros, des CDD,
ça peut durer des années, souvent à l'étranger, etc...
Sur le plan personnel, c'est un truc un peu difficile
et voilà, j'avais envie d’arrêter les frais
et de chercher un emploi stable.
Que penses-tu de la recherche scientifique en France ?
Alors, ça peut vouloir dire plein de choses cette question.
Le recherche scientifique en France est
quand même globalement d'un très bon niveau,
surtout dans certaines disciplines.
Ce qui m'attriste c'est qu'elle est peu considérée,
moi je l'ai bien vu parce en plus j'ai passé du temps
aux Etats-Unis où là c'est complètement différent
parce que la recherche est un truc qui est prestigieux.
Alors ce n'est pas tellement le prestige mais c'est le fait que
c'est quelque chose qui a de la considération dans la société,
alors qu'en France, la recherche n'est pas très très valorisée.
Je pense que ça aura plein
de conséquences un peu néfastes à terme.
Un chercheur qui cherche on en trouve,
mais des chercheurs qui trouvent on en cherche ?
Alors voilà, exemple parfait de ce que je viens de dire,
je pense que cette phrase précisément représente
à elle seule 50% des raisons pour lesquelles
on ne considère pas la recherche en France,
que les chercheurs sont sujets de moqueries, etc...
Je trouve ça grave parce que je pense
qu'une société qui méprise la recherche,
du coup va finir par éteindre à la fois
ses compétences scientifiques, sa technologie,
ses innovations et à terme, tout ça c'est la perte
au niveau tout simplement des emplois
et je pense que cette phrase précisément
est une des causes du fait qu'on ne considère pas
la recherche et les chercheurs
donc j'en veux beaucoup à ceux
qui disent cette phrase, j'en suis désolé.
Voilà, c'est terminé, merci à tous ceux
qui ont suivi cette longue FAQ jusqu'au bout
et on se retrouve bientôt pour des vraies vidéos cette fois.
♪ [Musique] ♪